find the measurement of angle c a d so
angle c a d so this this angle right
over here the measure of that angle and
let's just call it x so that i don't
have to keep writing the measure of
angle c a d and the one thing that might
jump out at you is that the other angles
measures are given here 50 degrees 45
degrees and 37 degrees the other thing
that might jump out at you if you take
the outer edge of all of these angles
which are adjacent to each other if you
take the outer edge it forms a straight
angle so this entire angle is going to
be 180 degrees or another way to think
about it the measure of each of these
angles when you add them all together
need to be equal to 180 degrees and
that's what we need to solve this
problem because we have x
x plus 50
15 orange x plus 50
plus 45
plus 45
plus
37
plus 37 is going to be equal to
180 degrees
is going to be equal to 180 and now
these let's see 50 plus 45 is 95 95 plus
30 is 125 plus 7 is 132 so all of that
is 132 we can subtract 132 from both
sides
132 subtract 132
on our left hand side we're left just
with an x on our right hand side 180
minus 32 is 48
and we're done x is equal to this the
measure of this angle right over here is
equal to 48 degrees